merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
il y a trois ans des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 faisait plus de 130 morts
et plus de 400 blessés au stade de
france sur les terrasses du restaurant
et au bataclan la barbarie islamiste a
fait couler le sang d'innocents à paris
mais aussi à nice à marseille à toulouse
à saint-etienne du rouvray à carcassonne
a trade nous pensons très fort ce jour
aux victimes et aux familles toujours
dans la douleur nous rendons hommage aux
gendarmes aux policiers et secours qui
ont vécu l'horreur absolue de ces crimes
la guerre contre la barbarie et le
terrorisme islamiste n'est pas finie et
les 55 projets d'attentât déjouée sur
notre sol depuis 2013 dont six cette
année atteste que la menace est toujours
bien présente comment gagner ce combat
monsieur le premier ministre comment
lutter contre ce fléau quand votre
ministre de l'intérieur ne désigne pas
les racines de ce malaise et de cette
menace
l'islamisme radical et le
communautarisme terreau fertile de la
radicalisation ils sont ce nouvel
antisémitisme dont votre gouvernement
refuse de parler quand allez-vous
prendre conscience monsieur le premier
ministre qu'il faut réarmer moralement
notre pays qu'il faut reconquérir les
esprits au nom de la république et de
tous ceux qui se reconnaissent en elle
pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
ce matin avec
des parlementaires de
seine-saint-denis et de paris il sut
évidemment de toutes les familles
politiques
nous avons rendu un hommage aux victimes
des attaques du 13 novembre 2015 nous
l'avons fait à saint denis puis sur
l'ensemble des lieux qui ont été frappés
par ces actes le 13 novembre 2015
je peux vous dire madame la sénatrice
que à l'occasion de ces cérémonies
l'émotion était présente chez les
familles évidemment chez les victimes
qui revenant sur les lieux de ces
attentats
revivez une fois de plus car comme
beaucoup d'entre elles me l'ont dit
elles revivent tous les jours ses actes
elle était très vive aussi chez les
policiers
singulièrement ceux de la berri mais pas
seulement chez les pompiers chez les
médecins du samu chez les médecins des
différents hôpitaux de la place
parisienne chez les secouristes et aux
fonds chez tous ceux qui ont une mémoire
très vive de la façon dont ils ont vécu
ces actes terroristes je voudrais
m'associer comme vous madame la
sénatrice un hommage qui est rendu par
le sénat à tous ceux qui ce jour-là au
fait de leur mieux et on fait souvent
encore bien plus pour être à la hauteur
des enjeux est à la hauteur du drame qui
se noue vers vous interroger le
gouvernement sur
ce que nous voulons faire pour continuer
à protéger les français je voudrais vous
dire madame la sénatrice d'abord que le
débat selon lequel nous nommerions pas
la menace à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés est un débat qui est clos et
qui est révolu car
ce gouvernement comme les gouvernements
précédents ont indiqué que l'ennemi
était connu qu'il prenait la forme du
terrorisme islamiste et que notre
objectif c'était de le combattre et de
fer prévu voir ce que nous sommes car
madame la sénatrice les terroristes qui
ont attaqué notre pays le 13 novembre
2015 ne voulait pas entre guillemets
conquérir un territoire ils ne voulaient
pas défaire les institutions de la
république qu'il voulait attaquer ce que
nous sommes notre liberté notre façon de
vivre notre sens de la fête
notre capacité à débattre et même d'une
certaine façon à ne pas être d'accord
fondamentalement ce qu'est la démocratie
et la république française
et c'est ça que nous devons défendre
d'abord en continuant à être nous-mêmes
bien entendu et en affirmant ce que nous
sommes en le revendiquant en montrant et
en assumant et puis ensuite évidemment
d'autant nos forces de sécurité
intérieure comme d'ailleurs nos armes et
des moyens indispensables dont ils ont
besoin pour garantir la sécurité des
français vous avez évoqué un certain
nombre d'attentats qui ont été déjoués
depuis le 13 novembre 2015
je peux vous dire madame la sénatrice
que la menace que vous évoquez n'a pas
disparu elle était évidemment très
présente nous en sommes tous
parfaitement conscient
le ministre de l'intérieur le secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
et je suis en suis sur l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
essayons et nous faisons dans la
continuité d'une certaine façon de ce
qui a déjà été engagée de réarmer notre
pays de faire en sorte que les forces de
sécurité dispose de plus de moyens et de
plus d'effectifs c'est indispensable si
on veut apporter un élément de la
réponse que nos forces armées disposent
de bien plus de moyens que ceux dont
elle pouvait auparavant se prévaloir
pour là encore pouvoir permettre de
faire prévaloir nos intérêts à
l'extérieur de nos frontières et puis ce
combat ce n'est pas simplement un combat
sécuritaire même s'il est indispensable
et qu'il ne faut pas le prendre avec
aucune forme de naïveté c'est aussi un
combat culturel un combat social un
combat de républicains sur tout l'est
sur tous les endroits du territoire et
dans tous les domaines vous regardez la
menace
et la réalité en face nous le faisons
sans esprit de polémique madame la
sénatrice avec beaucoup de détermination
avec beaucoup de moyens aussi des moyens
qui peut être à une certaine époque nous
ont fait défaut des moyens sur lequel
nous nous sommes engagés pour faire en
sorte que sans pouvoir en rien garantir
à nos concitoyens le le risque zéro je
ne le ferai jamais car ce n'est pas
tenable mais en faisant en sorte que
nous fassions tout ce que nous pouvons
faire pour garantir à nos concitoyens le
plus haut niveau de sécurité auxquels
ils ont droit je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
monsieur premier mini jeux vous remercie
de votre réponse j'entends que vous ne
seriez plus aujourd'hui dans le déni
force est de constater que jusqu'à
présent ce n'était pas le cas et que le
déni n'est pas une solution et que je
suis désolé quand on ne nomme pas
l'islamisme radical eh bien on ne traite
pas à fond ce sujet et le silence n'a
fait que trop durer alors si aujourd'hui
résolument vous sortez de ce silence eh
bien j'espère que ce sera vraiment le
cas parce que jusqu alors le silence
empêcher la france de lutter
efficacement contre ce fléau